speaking of conflicts probably the
biggest conflict recently and also in
terms of the impact on the West the
conflict probably that is driving many
of the political shifts and problems and
challenges and transformations and also
maybe opportunities that we see now in
the West with nationalism and all of
this kind of stuff a lot of it seems to
be linked to the conflict in Syria and
then the ensuing refugee crisis and and
it's like one big snowball it's that's
happened so in five minutes I mean not
in five minutes or less but just explain
for anyone who doesn't understand or
know much about it how has that happened
what has happened was it the the
collapse of Iraq and the emergence of
Isis there that then spread into Syria
is that really a stupid question you're
looking me like it is oh no that's not
stupid but I mean it's not accurate it's
not a stupid question
no I lived in Syria for in 2007-2008 and
in that year none of us who were living
there would have thought that that this
was that the country was going to become
the Byward first national collapse and
civil war death it didn't seem like that
was on the cards four years later it
began you know originally the the Arab
the the episode I think it's the fifth
or fourth fifth episode of our podcast
conflicted deals with the Syrian civil
war and Haman had a lot of interesting
things to say about it that I didn't
know one of the things he said which is
that the protests that broke out in
Syria during the beginning of the Arab
Spring you know which was this much this
region-wide uprising movement the
protests in Syria focused very clearly
on essentially on police brutality in
that in that country it was it had
become de rigueur for the police within
Syria to kidnap young 11 12 year old
boys raped them and deposit them in
dumpsters as a way of scaring local
populations into behaving and that's
terrible
and so they they were rallying something
like that happened in a southern town
they routed they empowered I guess or
inspired by the Arab Spring they rose up
and said well we actually would like
this to stop they petitioned the
President Bashar al-assad whom they had
no interest in toppling you know come on
stop just stop this you know bring the
police under control instead of doing
that he ordered or allowed the police to
fire in the crowds and then then it just
became then it became a violent uprising
Syria is is extremely important
geographically it's right there in the
middle it borders Turkey which is this
very strong NATO
state which had for 400 years ruled
Syria of course it borders you know
Jordan which is a linchpin in the
American security apparatus the
Jordanian Secret sort of CIA effectively
is one of the world's best and most
important in in combating Islamic
terrorism at borders Israel we know what
that means and that borders Lebanon
largely a failed state for 35 years so
you know it's very and and Iraq which by
that point was kind of a failed state as
well so it's very important the this and
it Syria also has the misfortune of
being a place where a lot of apocalyptic
stories that that Muslims and Islamists
especially tell themselves about the end
of days lots of villages are meant to
play key roles in the story that brings
the return of Jesus and and and and the
judgment of the world and they assure
again of you know that the end times
sadly Syria is like the battleground for
that in Muslim eschatology so when a
civil war broke out there it was a lot
of you know radical Islamist extremist
jihadists thought the prophecies are
coming true you see you know it's all
happening in Syria so they kind of piled
in hoping to lure the west into
intervening because that's all part of
the end of times scenario I mean in in
the scenarios it's the Roman Empire
which intervenes and they think that the
Roman Empire just stands for the West
now so they were trying to lure the West
in
because they thought that if they could
do that then the end of times would
happen and and they believed the end of
times will result in their in their
favor
so Syria was to some extent like a
sacrificed on that on the altar of those
sorts of religious ideas which is why
there were so many Islamist groups Iran
Iranian Islamist actors got involved
because they Iran has the same
eschatological sort of ideas as the
Sunnis that they then started to fight
and it became a total mess and then you
know Turkey got involved obviously
because the Kurds were involved in the
turkey has Kurds and they don't want the
Kurds to rebel in Turkey and then and
then then because of the Tartus naval
base Russia got involved and then Obama
didn't didn't actually respect the red
lines he'd drawn so Russia realized oh
we can just actually actually fight a
war here so they were throwing barrel
bombs and bombing neighborhoods in
America wasn't doing anything and then
Isis rose yeah
so as a result of which there was
tremendous migration away from Syria
because who would you know live that
terrible and you know a lot of that
migration went into Turkey which you
know and then the UN and other
institutions set up refugee camps but
then and a lot of those migrants wanted
to get in get to Europe for for safety
reasons and also like many migrants from
everywhere for economic reasons and that
became that trickle became a flood I
mean I think there was some bad there
was some manipulation by the Turkish
government they were letting a lot of
migrants in it was - they weren't
policing migration because they wanted
to use it as a bargaining chip with
particularly the Germans but EU in
general for various concessions which
they received which is why then they
stopped letting the migrants through so
it all became a mess and that famously
angular Merkel kind of said come come
come and then like 2 million over a
course of a summer came and that freaked
out the Hungarians and absolutely you
know they do the poor Greeks who are
already on their knees they were they
couldn't cope with all of these migrants
[Music]